okay i think it's gonna work i need to
know let me know in the chat box
if you guys
if this works the audio and whatnot
um so i said this in the previous
streams but i've had i've had issues
guys with
streaming um basically i need you guys
to let me know what i should react to
and yeah send those in the chat
i'm probably just gonna pick like a
kevin samuels or something just to start
it off
today we're focusing on red pill i'm
gonna do rap videos a different day
but yeah
um
let me let me grab
let me make sure this is working because
you never know i've had issues
oh yeah it's working we're okay
um okay what i'm gonna start with
um
[Music]
[Music]
i think these look interesting to you
um oh actually i watched kevin samuels's
video last night because
i
it says i watched it here but i did not
actually
let me watch his monologue
oh no i always put everything on 2x but
i shouldn't do that when i'm reacting
shirley stuck a whole
horn in f54
[Music]
how we doing how we doing how we doing
how we doing welcome back welcome back
welcome back
camera one
camera two camera three
uh
everybody loves my uh
my uh things i'm gonna show you
something
cause i finally got the ones i wanted
so it was
weird it was like
yeah baby we keeps it moving keeps it
grooving over here that's what we do
um also put what you want me to react to
in the chat
um
i will react to them but i'm going to
react to this first but then i'm going
to get to other [ __ ] later
[Music]
i apologize i've been out
with uh the omnicron
yeah
[Music]
and you know it was it was
weird it was like
almost like a cold but i knew too many
people who had it so i wasn't taking any
chances
so we had to take time off so we're
starting to get back in the in the
groove of things
and as we do that
we're going to get back into the shows
candle of the evening laurier 62
from leylabo
fragrance of the evening
from mason francis curtis young
we have respectfully
i don't care baccarat rouge 5-4-0
the original og
so let's see what we got going on
um in the chat room
you said bro i'm just attract i'm
distracted i know
i you know there are so many conspiracy
theories
what's going on bentley bear
so many conspiracy theories apparently
these are hypnotism devices
to where i used to hypnotize people
but talking about what would work to be
honest on me
we got going
on uh shout out to the attorney and the
realtor
the new series that i'm about to debut
uh
uh live conversations from the field
where the work is real i'ma tell you man
at least once a week
somewhere around this country i am
sitting down with two or more
professional attractive women
talking about the stuff we talk about
here
and i'm gonna start bringing you guys
that content while protecting those
people's identity their brand and their
business
because there is there is uh the we the
conversation
has matured
yeah we went from average at best you
know we went we we went from not that
whole thing average at best to to where
we're at now and look at you
you're average at best yeah we went from
average at best to
all other things to you know the
phd in the cookbook and also but the
conversation has matured
and one of the things that i know more
than anything else on youtube is i have
the skill set the ability and the desire
to keep moving the conversation forward
i want to talk to the kind of women that
you would want to be dealing with
that's going to be the difference maker
it's one thing to talk to women
but what good is it to talk to women who
aren't in the ballpark
aren't in the conversation
and in order to do that you have to have
a different conversation on a different
level
so if you're not down for that journey
if you still want to see kicking outs
and slamming them and hanging up and
this and that uh well
the platform evolves
i reflect energy
okay
this is actually
a good change i think because
what good does it do to just keep
talking to hoes and girls that you don't
want to date
isn't it better to
talk with girls that you want to date
and you'd like to get to know
right um someone in the chat someone in
the chat said um are we just gonna
listen to his monologue
they last 50 years um i actually only
wanted to listen to his monologue
and more often than not even when you
sit down with somebody you disagree with
they're not going to be acting crazy so
you're going to have a conversation
that's going to be balanced and that is
better because we are trying to move the
conversation forward so in that regard
be on the lookout
for a new email address i'm going to
drop if you want to be interviewed on
the show
i'm going to do a combination of either
the infield
on the show
um
but what i really what i'm doing is i'm
bringing you guys what really happens in
the world last night i was late to
instagram because i was having an
in-depth conversation with an attorney
and a realtor
which is like conversations i have every
day
um
now what i was going to talk about
tonight
uh it was going to be off of a
a breakdown of a segment that i saw on
cruise season ballot sexes
well he had this woman sitting next to
poor man's podcast but you know what i'm
going to play a little bit of it i'm
going to play a little bit of it from
his channel and then i'm going to lead
it on into my broadcast do me a favor
keep the likes up because guess what
your godfather got skills
i can run a show with personality
charisma
and the ability to monologue
and deal with the people in prison in
person
we had this woman
why because is that his dms
did he leak his dms
you can't see it but if you look at the
corner
that's funny i do this for real
i live this i be this i'm just like you
i came from single parent household
christian family we were poor broke
coming up we all make ourselves
no what separates me kevin
kevin stop oh my gosh
he has his dms in the corner you can't
see it because of my live stream i'm
over it
oh no kevin
just do the work kevin but anyway let's
get on into this i want to play a little
bit of this broadcast
um because it was an important it was an
important show
um but i don't know because she's
dealing with a man i think the problem
is a lot of women think providing is
abundance nowadays but i'm going to
break down if you know anything about
finances you know that a man can have a
house with 50k
you know that but see women don't even
have a concept of the money not the
house you want not the household not the
house you want that's that's hypergamy
that's you wanting more it's okay it's
future
future
he has like what tensions
nba young boy one ten of them all of
them girl
so you have one sexually irresponsible
man but you have seven sexually
irresponsible women or irresponsible
women
you want
to be with based on
appearance because you have to be
sexually and physically attracted to a
person this show is a leading into what
we're doing why do we have to accept the
bare minimum but for men we have to come
with a hundred percent we have to check
off every box but as women we have to be
like you know what
he provides
he he's he's loyal so therefore he
doesn't have to be physically attractive
i want to know what kevin uses
for this software because his audio is
great and so is this video what what
boxes
this is a conversation that happened on
the podcast down in houston brothers
called crew season
you see this woman and poor man's
podcast having a conversation
um
i reached out to her and i told her i
was going to be actually breaking this
video down i thought i was going to do
it last week but i was still sick so i
let her know that i'm going to be
talking about this
i love
real time conversations
because there are things in this
conversation that i really want to point
out because
let's just get to it some of the most
interesting things going on with today's
modern superhero females
are y'all checking out let me know what
you we try we check off everything
we are smart okay we provide we're good
wife
i like he's like low-key sassy we're
good mothers
no you're not good wives only twenty one
and four you were married so you're not
good wives
wanna yeah that's true
i don't even we're not even in shape
this is myself included i am not above
any of this stuff like we are not
perfect
you know
like
if i look at my bmi i should be 10 15
pounds later and let me tell you i have
a really hard time with that stuff that
is something i struggle with and i'm
working on but
yeah i we can't say we're perfect and
then we check every box we don't
before you were married
good mothers you could judge the
mothering by the outcome look at where
the children are in our community black
boys reading at a fourth grade level see
a lot of this stuff wouldn't have slid
by me i'd have shut some of this [ __ ]
down
you don't just get to say something
because you think it
but this is what this is what's going on
in modern relationship with these modern
ev avengers
modern avengers i'm calling them
averagers average at best
modern average at best and look at you
you're average at best
call me crazy how can you be a summer
pro athlete and not in shape no i'm in
shape guys it's completely different i
am a hundred percent in shape
um i can deadlift a lot i can run a mile
i can do any athletic thing
um the issue
i mean not any i can't do a pull-up but
the issue is um i eat bad so you cannot
work a bad diet it doesn't matter how
much you work out
but you know i'm working on it you think
about the avengers marvel superheroes
what made them it all start
it all started off with uh that's real
crystal
it all started off with one
person tony stark iron man kicked off
the marvel universe
uh
phase three
the incredible hulk
bruce banner
steve rogers captain america hawkeye
widow uh
thor
we have greater and lesser villains but
one thing is
every one of these people had a story
just like we're going to talk about
and when we talk about our modern
averages
we're talking about
if if the avengers were earth's
mightiest heroes the averages of the
unmarriageables
you got the doctor
you've got the lawyer
you've got
the realtor
you've got the phd you've got the
entrepreneur you got the nurse
and then you got some lesser heroes oh
i'm gonna break it all the way down
they're gonna get their own they're
gonna get their own broadcast they're
gonna get their own powers they're gonna
get their own series because every one
of you guys out there know an averager
average bro isn't the majority of people
average
not everyone can be special
not everyone can be hot
it's okay
want superhero luxury outcomes and your
average at best all right let me tell
you guys most girls they say they want
that lifestyle they don't they have no
idea what comes with it
i would say i
i grew up in like a first generational
wealth family and that's very different
than like a multi-generational wealth
but
i'm sorry
but even my dad
like he expected [ __ ] from my mom my mom
worked all the time for his business
um
like my mom was an extremely hard worker
their marriage would not have lasted if
she wasn't a hard worker
and these girls think that they'll marry
these guys and just get to do nothing
and it's just not the case i don't think
my last boyfriend was famous
and
i don't think most girls know what comes
with that either
you are you secure enough to deal with
girls coming at your
at your boyfriend constantly
like dming him all the time
are you are you ready for that i sure as
hell wasn't like that wasn't why we
broke up but
i'm telling you it gives you
insecurities that
that you
you really aren't ready for and i was
not ready for
we have a story first time he posted or
i posted with him he
the whole internet was talking about
how much much less attractive i was than
the last girl he talked to like imagine
that that sort of
you know luckily i'm not super insecure
but like if i was super insecure i
that would really get to me and really
you know like who knows what i would do
to my face to make it better but yeah
good we come from good homes we can cook
we can clean we're good
[Music]
you say they can cook
i don't need a cookbook she said they
can cook
i don't need a cookbook
if if if modern women were everything
this woman is saying they were they
would be married at a rate like their
four mothers
and i feel like as women i um what did
he say
can we cook no
oh my god
i'm an okay cook i'm not bad but no i
can't cook it's not not like my grandma
could cook
um
who said that
to you guys you dated no um it was the
internet like people
oh my gosh it was i posted a video with
him and if you go to the comments
section everyone was like downgrade the
the most liked liked comment was you
downgraded
i don't remember what it was something
some comment about him downgrading and
people were making like stitches and
duets just talking about how
unattractive i was
in that video had almost a million views
yeah not fun not fun
unfortunately we have to settle men you
are not being realistic then why not
because social media is fake
so you're allowing social media to weigh
in on a decision on somebody do you know
what i'm saying so if i post it if a man
if a man posted himself naked
repeatedly on social media you saying
are you saying that you will bypass what
he repeatedly shows and give that man a
chance
i'm not i mean i'm not into that so no
i'm a speaker i'm not into that so no no
no no he's posting himself naked okay
cool he's showing him i'm not into that
but i'm just saying that so if you see
okay i get it
if you meet a girl let's let's give this
situation you meet a girl out right and
like y'all exchange numbers and um later
on the night y'all exchange instagram
you know what i'm saying are you telling
me that you're really like going through
every picture and just like
i'm gonna do a quick browse if she's
giving me your social media image you've
heard that absolutely okay because she
created that for herself
okay like if if there's a man that's
doing drugs and always posting money
what are you gonna assume about him
you're not gonna think about his
character you're gonna think this man is
flashy all they trying to do is sell
drugs or he just flashing the money he's
just showing his call right and that's
why rich people find that stuff trashy
to show your money your cars all that
stuff on social media rich people do not
are not impressed by that we're not
i'm not where i'm not rich just coming
from
you know like my parents know a lot of
very successful people and it looks
trashy
and it's the same thing with showing
your body on social media i tell this to
my sister
she doesn't really listen but um
that image that you portray on social
media is what people are going to assume
about you now you can't say oh
like it's the viewer's fault for not
trying to get to know everything about
me when the stuff i put out says one
thing
oh no what did i do okay
oh wait why don't go okay or whatever
that's what you're gonna assume with
them because that's what they posted if
i'm always posting i'm working if i'm
posting that i have a business here a
business there you're gonna be like that
man is on his stuff you don't even have
to
showing actually you're not the reason
why failed relationship actually happens
because there's become a pattern of
women staying through these things could
even think about it
i want you guys to ask yourself a
question are any of the women that you
hear speaking
where is the affection good faith and
femininity
close your eyes
and i want you to pay attention to the
tonality in the voice
then i want you to open your eyes close
your ears and i want you to look at the
body positions
stop listening to the words and start
looking at the outcomes
you ask most women right what are they
gonna say [ __ ] ain't [ __ ] all [ __ ]
cheat even men now will tell you you're
not gonna find [ __ ] that's not gonna
cheat on you because they've let us feed
into that narrative so long that we
believe that now so i feel like if as
women we say no i'm gonna find a [ __ ]
that's not gonna cheat on me then when a
[ __ ] does cheat on you
you gonna leave
i want to know why i won't want to find
a [ __ ] anyway
shout out to minister jeff you know he
does some interesting work it's it's
extremely edgy
but he makes a point
today
when you're out and about are you more
likely of if something jumps off
it's far more likely you're going to see
something jumping off between women
throwing them hands
where's all this aggression and anger
coming from
these picked up super i think that
men don't check women anymore
so
how many couples do you guys know where
the woman walks all over the man
i know a lot i could
a decent amount i you know um
that shouldn't be the case you know
so
because of that we have women who don't
have consequences because you can't
you can't hit a girl without having any
consequences
yourself so if a girl's mouthing off or
hitting someone or doing any of that she
has no consequences and if you take
the consequences away from people
bad things happen i am so glad i have
consequences for my actions
like when i do something wrong typically
there is a consequence
i'm not really i'm not disagreeable i
don't i'm not a fighter i'm kind of
awkward
that's just i don't i don't have it in
me but
oftentimes
you know
if you don't check women you know
that's what becomes you know
anyways for
hours
the averages
y'all see where we're going with this
you're starting to see the origin story
of each one of
the community's mightiest heroes
[Laughter]
but now i feel like women are so sick
and so cornered into that narrative that
when a [ __ ] does cheat on her she's
like well he does this this
we could work through this
you know and i feel like if we as women
stop thinking like that then maybe we'd
actually i don't want to say gifts i
just don't care what other people do
if you want to stay with your guy that
cheats on you that is that is not my
problem if you don't complain to me
about it
i do not care
i don't i don't even pick me on this but
i'm saying like i do feel like we need
to stop giving [ __ ] grace i'm not
gonna lie i mean hi jeffrey hey william
hey tom
hey mrs williamson hey mr jacobson i'd
like you to meet my wife keisha hey how
you doing what's up [ __ ] what these
[ __ ] over here doing
hey [ __ ] give me one of them champagnes
[Laughter]
no no don't worry about it keisha where
it worked yeah [ __ ] all that [ __ ] [ __ ]
a little bathroom man [ __ ]
the marriage is different in
relationships
no if we're going to be honest the
average woman
typically picks
right
in the order that you said because when
you ask a question off the top usually
people respond with what's off the top
okay right your first things that you
listed had nothing to do with what men
want and women so what do y'all want and
that's the problem we want
big feminine friendly cooperative
submissive childless
you failed the fitness test
eight
that is the one thing i appreciate about
kevin samuels is he really puts girls on
game to be honest
a lot of stuff when i
was younger i never even thought of i
never even thought about like cooking
for a guy or
you know i'm naturally friendly that's
that's pretty normal for me but
i don't know just going out of your way
to like do stuff for them i know it
seems simple but
as a girl you're always afraid to like
come off too strong you know
and
yeah and he's like no you shouldn't
be afraid to do that eight percent of
the women failed the fitness test
today it is not uncommon to see women
who weigh more than men at their average
height but hey you're superheroes you're
at your fighting weight you got to be
able to take on thanos
and uh
um
you know the dark elves
and and ultron and galactus
and kang the conqueror
man come on why are we going there
the point i was going to do is break
down this video and show you some of the
outright
hypocrisy that a lot of modern women
were willing to spout but a lot of you
guys have already seen it and there have
been other breakdowns that have shown
that when people when when women started
failing in the argument they started
making up [ __ ] and lying
and this is where i need men to start
getting better stop allowing women to
lie
this is what my life talked about said
brittany renner and pj washington was
married now it's all kind of
same insults guilt and the need to be
right why is this important because when
you're out and about dealing with the
new avengers the averagers
they they get their superpowers from the
sisterhood scrolls and sign language
like if you look at superheroes they all
tend to have
super human strength endurance stamina
some sort of regenerative process you
know all heroes tend to have baseline
stuff superhuman strength endurance and
healing factors something like that
whether it's luke age or super i don't
get any of these i don't i don't i don't
know this stuff oh wolverine but then
you start looking at different different
variations of heroes some have
telekinesis powers some people have
cosmic powers this that yeah we're gonna
break down every one
of these averages that we're going to
start first
with the attorney
the attorney
the attorney
is like
um i've always said it's my worst fear
to marry a lawyer you lose every fight
every fight you'll never win you'll
never get your way iron man
she's the one that's loud unless it's
tla loki call me proud sorry don't tell
him i said that out in front telling you
that she don't need no man she's the one
that if you can find her in any setting
she's willing to have the argument she
is literally tony stark's machismo and
arrogance in female form oh you gonna
have your own series counselor
because one thing attorneys love to do
is argue
they love to debate they love to deal
with the hypothetical but here's the
problem with all of these averages
they spend so much time in their careers
doing jobs and work that require
emotional labor
that they have really nothing left
to give to the kind of man they say they
want to be with
you think youtube is emotional labor
i don't think so
so you got the attorney
and if you guys go back to the one
broadcast i say look at the kind of
women that high value men tend to avoid
and they're all on that list
but we're going to deal with the women
who are strictly professional
because i'm not going to go down to some
of the areas where guys are like i don't
know if i would marry that person we're
going to deal with the professional
women
the attorney
you find her in every group
she's the one that wants to argue
everywhere you go
and it's funny
a lot of attorneys tend to have been
married
probably 50 of them divorced though and
the ones that are still married is [ __ ]
about their husbands
i would do i know any lawyers i don't
think i do
trying to think
i always when i watch stuff i always
think if does this apply to me in my
world in real life
um
and i don't i don't think so i don't
know any lawyers that i can think of off
the top of my head all the lawyers i
know are men love to
it is uncommon
to me tanya stark
the attorney
who is
happily
married who speaks well of her husband
and
oh yeah
she's she's usually walking around in
the hulkbuster
oh my god oh my god
look at the hell he did lie
baby this is the best
she normally rolling around in that
goddamn hulk bump
oh my god
oh jesus oh
calm down kevin
all right
she's gonna get our own series
you got it coming counselor
because every counselor i meet they want
to sit down and talk to me about
relationships and well you open to a
different perspective and sure
but
it's amazing
because the attorney
is the focal point of the avengers group
the averages she's the main agent of
chaos amongst her friends she's the
woman that keeps most of them single
because this is the woman that will tell
you that forget the facts the data
statistics god has something for you and
da da da oh god
i do not i i for real do not know
any lawyers
i don't have that many friends anymore i
will say when i talk about people i know
i talk about people i used to know
mostly because
i've moved it's very hard to maintain
friendships when you move around so much
i have like one or two girls that i've
known a really long time
once an engineer
one is a nanny
and the rest
yeah i
in and out better than i believe this
and that i believe you can fly and i
mean it's just like
i had this conversation i had last night
is the conversation i have every week
that's why i'm going to break it down
and show you guys real world when i was
talking to her i was like man i see i
meet you every day
i asked one question in the conversation
ma'am do you make any room
or do you make the are you open to the
possibility that me and your friend here
are experiencing you as being
argumentative
or not being constructive
took up fully 30 seconds to
say
well i guess i could
dude
this is going to be an incredible series
the attorney
the attorney
i want you to go back to the what if
series on uh marvel when they were
fighting uh
infinity ultron and infinity ultron
figured out that
strain a strange supreme doctor strange
supreme was the one
that was superpowering everybody else he
said if i get you or they all fall
she is strained supreme she's the one
that powers them all
who's next
well then you get next you get
the realtor
the realtor do you have a realtor friend
i haven't talked to her in a couple
years but let me let's see is the the
girl that went to school
probably something humanity's business
but she found marketing she found her
way into real estate that's true the
girl i know sales
now she's not typically just regular
real estate she tends to probably be in
you know
[Music]
i don't they're not always in luxury
real estate but they want to be
selling high-end homes true yes
they all do well she does the attorney
does well the realtor does well
the realtor
is the one that usually wants to be
married because she's always showing
homes to happy families and this and
that
yeah i don't i haven't talked to her in
a while but she always wanted a
boyfriend yeah ah
and it's the same story over and over
again
and they're really trying
the realtors sit here and watch this
show they watch this show but they can't
tell their friend the attorney that they
watch this show because their friend the
attorney will start trying to hammer on
them why do you watch that you don't
need to do that all you need is god and
me and i can show you what's going on
guys this all played out last night
all of this played out for real and the
thing is it's plays out every night
somewhere around this country
in atlanta i see it all the time groups
of women talking to one another and i
can point out which avenger they are
which averager they are you're the
attorney you're the realtor
well the realtor there's hope for the
realtors
i would say i would say there's hope for
that girl i could see her getting buried
at some point attorneys like i said half
of them are married and the ones and the
ones that the the ones that the half
that are divorced
um
or unmarried
and the ones that are married
they still talk crazy
anyway they just like to argue
and they love that need to be right why
is this important
so what's next
you got the attorney
you got the realtor
those are the two that roll the most
together
they're that's the that's the they're
the like you know the sith and this and
the sith apprentice
but there's a bigger group they're like
captain man it's like the realtor is
like captain america
and
the attorneys like iron man
who comes in next well who would be the
third avenger
the third avenger arguably would be thor
thor would be arguably the third avenger
and which one is this
i'm a phd
the third avenger
or averager is going to be
the physician
slash nurse
okay i know a couple nurses i know i
know a good amount of nurses
oh i'm gonna go to hell
oh my god the physician slash nurse okay
the physician makes more money than the
nurse but they do roughly the same
things they have jobs that are immensely
taxing to their emotional
uh
to their emotional load
they have professional licenses to
managers they have patient loads they
have insurance they got all this kind of
stuff so they are emotionally drained
okay when they leave work they got
barely enough
you have two very two my physician i
think she's a pa or in school to be a pa
she's married
the
the my nurse friends i have two ones
married once versions the workout
version and non-workout version the
non-workout version
[Music]
it's a wrap for her
but most of them have some sort of
workout because they have to stay on
their feet a lot
or they have to work longer hours a lot
of these women work out
but they do emotional labor
and these women are around
physicians male physicians they're
around men of value
they know everything
they know everything so you could either
say they're like
actually take their back they're not
thor they're not thor scratch they're
like doctor strange
they're like doctor strange because
doctor strange has the time stone
they're like doctor strange and they got
a doctor title i'm a phd
they float in all kinds of worlds they
live in this world they can go to a
remote and they go to the multiverse
they can [ __ ] with the tva they can do
all of it
um
i will say there is something to say
about spending a lot of emotional labor
um one of the girls i'm thinking of
definitely had a lot of time trouble
with dating um i think it's more because
she's
she kind of does everything she's very
pretty but she does everything wrong in
my opinion like drinks a lot
very
left i guess um
but yeah the other girl
is like happily married that's what i
know
so the nurse and the physician
are like dr strange
the attorneys like iron man
the realtors like captain america
what do you want to get to next oh let
me pull up my list let me pull up my
list and we're going to fill these in
and these may change a little bit over
time
what's the next one that we have the
next ones we have on the list
because our combined nursing physician
we have the entrepreneur
the i don't know
i think that would be me and the friend
group
oh no i'm nervous entrepreneur is every
bit of black widow
oh my god
because black widow was a master of
disguise a doppelganger entrepreneur
could mean any goddamn thing oh okay
so every time you hear a woman that says
i'm an entrepreneur just think in your
mind hi natasha romanov
oh okay i don't know if i'd be that i
just say youtuber
but
let me know in the comments would i
count oh my god i'm going to hell
oh
they're black widow assassins
because they kill hopes
they kill dreams because they're under
that nerve agent execute order 66.
they're under ex they call it widow
juice in the in the the mcu over here
they're under order 66.
yeah they go to the red room they go get
red kool-aid oh [ __ ] we are going there
they are black widow so all you
entrepreneurs i sell hair i sell nails i
sell extensions
any entrepreneur will do
all of them are black widows
all of them are black widows
what's the next one what have you got
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh my god
oh [ __ ]
if you got black widows
you gotta have a hawkeye
and who's the hawkeye
well you know who this is coming this is
the law enforcement military truck
driver
[Music]
law enforcement military truck driver
this is the chick to drive the buses
she's got masculine jobs
law enforcement military or truck driver
i don't know anyone i know one girl
that's a cop but she's gay so i don't
think
[Laughter]
clint barton like a [ __ ]
she's out here fighting
thanos with a stick in the stream
[Laughter]
oh clara barton ass
military
law enforcement
truck driving as
hawkeye
we gonna call him hawkeye we gonna call
him chickeny
oh [ __ ] we're going to name all these
people
so we got
we got iron man
tanya stark
telling you to tell you something tanya
is the attorney
we got the realtor captain america
stephanie rogers all right
then we got the nurse physician who is
dr strange
benedict cumberbatch
oh my god oh [ __ ] i wonder if my mom
knows any lawyers let me call her
just just for
i'll see what my mom says
i was just thinking about this
i'll see if she answers i'll keep
blending the video oh
oh i'm having too much fun
then here comes black widow's ass in
iron man 2 trying to slide up next to
the attorney
talking about she works illegal and
she's really a black widow
yeah i'm bringing all my geek powers out
right now let's go god damn it let's go
you got hawkeye
the military
construction worker
law enforcement
oh
i wasn't going to bring this one in but
i have to
well hey kevin
you're missing one
well there's one that fits in i'm gonna
call her the creative she's the hair
stylist the actress the massage
therapist
the one that wants the space babies you
know the the she she cause she's an
entrepreneur
but she really makes her own reality
you know it's scarlet weeds
oh
my god oh
one division in this [ __ ] what about
the engineer my friend's an engineer
yeah so their hair stylist so anytime
you see these women with these long
raptor claws
oh god and their hair stylist or
whatever i just want you to think one
division
hey maximoff
[ __ ]
oh my god
uh
the unmarriables
[Laughter]
oh
oh my god
oh
my
god
i know
y'all think i forgot i haven't forgot
the hr social worker teacher oh my old
roommate was
hr
do i know a teacher
i think i know a teacher haven't forgot
i haven't forgot brenda i haven't forgot
belinda banner
the incredible
i haven't forgotten belinda banner
[Laughter]
she has been with her boyfriend for a
couple years though so we'll see we'll
see she's got a phd in communication
oh
[ __ ]
phd
you know what i've said everyone i know
that has a degree in communications does
not know how to communicate
the audacity
kevin i need you to calm down you're
always angry you need to go to hr i
don't want to go down there you wouldn't
want to make me angry
oh my god
the incredible hulk
no she's actually pretty pleasant to be
honest
i'm just
i'm not saying i'm sure there's some
realness to this stuff i'm just thinking
of what i've seen
oh okay
what's the next clip
i think that's pretty much it i saw the
avengers um
what should i listen to next someone
said andrew tate
isn't communications a degree a lot of
student athletes go for
sure
um
okay let me know what i should watch
next because
i'm trying to
let me see what the someone said they
said andrew tate
andrew tate james bond review
okay
is this it
our bond is ruined
okay let's see
[Music]
zach if you sent me a video a couple
nights ago can you just dm me again so
it goes to the top and i can see what it
is
done
they [ __ ] did it
they destroyed the most alpha male on
the planet
the [ __ ] dawn dada james bond is a
black woman now i know this news came
out a few weeks ago i haven't done take
speeches blah blah blah blah and some of
you may be over it but i'm not over this
that was literally the number one guy
name the most alpha male guy you can
think of there'd be a huge portion of
the society would sit there and go well
james bond maybe he has women he can
fight there's cars you know he's copying
tate he's trying to be like tate you
know like he's me that's me that's me on
the screen
you are not as cool as james bond
i'm sorry okay i know
i'm sure he's got some cool qualities
you are not as cool as james bond i'm
sorry you cannot make that comparison i
didn't know i was gonna grow up to be
james bond but i could fight i've got an
aston i got all these chicks i'm
basically a [ __ ] spy
they killed me
so it hurts my feelings
and what pisses me off the most about
this dumb [ __ ]
is that this wokeness only goes one way
they will take a white male character
that has been white and male for 60
years and change it into a black female
but they will never is that what they
did i don't watch movies never take a
character that's been black and change
it white ever
they would never make shaft ed sheeran
they won't do that they'll only do it
one way
why
isn't that unfair isn't that racist you
have to make a decision the decision is
either this character has always been a
particular race and gender and therefore
we will continue along that path
or the decision is race and gender has
absolutely no bearing on this character
or any characters and in that case shaft
could be a white woman or ed sheeran or
some other worm but they won't do it
they only do it one way now i'm half
black half white so i have no real
he's half black
shut up
shut up he does not look half black
camp to join but i'm also logical enough
because when i say camp that's how the
world works nowadays the whites versus
the blacks it's so [ __ ] insane but
i'm logical enough to understand and see
this only goes one way
so it's not that's true it does only go
one way i'm
i just don't care who they cast as
movies that's my problem
a [ __ ] that doesn't affect me
i just i don't care that much about you
can only care about so many things am i
gonna throw fit if they make it a female
james bond
i don't care did they do a good job
probably not it's probably always
complaining fair
so this is an attack on two things one
is an attack on white people because i
think white people suffer from more
racism today than enter any other race
and that that sends people crazy when i
say that oh but the black people listen
i'm half black
i know that being a white man is going
to get you more [ __ ] today from
liberal idiots than being a black person
is going to get you from the right wing
there's like [ __ ] when 30 dudes in
the kkk like literally 20 or 30 guys
march they pretend there's a problem
where liberals march on mass and they
hate all white people so liberals are
the enemy and white people are the ones
who suffer from racism deal with it
slavery's over it's done deal with it
that's the first thing
so one is an attack on white people and
two more more importantly what it is is
an attack on the alpha male if you've
watched my channel long enough you will
know
and you would have been educated by now
that the archetype of a man a
traditional masculine man that idea is
under attack from every single angle the
idea of a man who is masculine is
unacceptable to the power to be because
masculine men are difficult to control
they want to control you so they like
liberal men they like weak men they like
women they like people whose minds can
be warped
that's true
a masculine man is very hard to control
that's when you date someone that's very
masculine it's like their way or the
highway you you got you have very little
say in things um
yeah
they're like liberals so they can put
something on tv without any facts
trump's racist no facts no proof
trump is racist and they repeat it trump
is racist trump trump is raped that's
what they want a masculine man will sit
there and go well trump's racial who the
[ __ ] are you but tell me who he is i
have met trump who are you who are you
telling me that but they don't want that
and james bond is the most masculine man
you can name the most masculine man they
can think of so so how do we [ __ ] with
this guy how do we [ __ ] with this
archetype we have a guy on tv driving
fast cars kicking ass and [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's going to encourage men to do
those three things we can't let that
happen we've already banned we've shadow
banned tate's [ __ ] account on youtube
now i hate it when people claim they're
shadow band
your content isn't that good i'm sorry
everyone when their views are low claim
shadow ban
did you did you complain when your views
were high
when they were pushing out your content
no
does it exist probably but when people
say that i automatically don't believe
them get rid of james bond let's make
him a black woman
i'm genuinely upset by this it's the the
most recent bond films with daniel craig
casino was good the other ones were all
[ __ ] anyway
they had huge plot holes and it really
bothered me i was watching them i'm
sitting there because i'm hyper
intelligent it annoyed me that i
discovered these huge plot holes like i
just thought of this now
how tall is he
there's no way he's that tall
[ __ ] i just thinking he's saying he's
james bond i'm like james bond has to be
taller than you no way sorry and that
was kind of rude that was real sorry
that was the last one
skyfall
and have you seen skyfall
no it was [ __ ] it was [ __ ] okay sky fall
i'm a guy i'm the bad guy in skyfall i
want to kill em so my plan is to get
caught and then escape and then because
i can tell the [ __ ] future i know
she's gonna be in this court case
because i blew up mi6 so i'm going to go
in there with a gun oh my god he's 6'3
he looks tiny
oh my god i was i was corrected quickly
i'm going to kill m
why do you have to get caught and escape
to walk into a courtroom why don't you
just walk in the courtroom why did you
get caught and escape why why add that
level of difficulty
two how the [ __ ] did you miss
you had this plan for years and you walk
in the courtroom and miss
you didn't do any training with the
[ __ ] pistol you you worked out how to
get in and out of mi6 but you didn't
[ __ ] do any training also he blew up
mi6 headquarters so that they had to use
their second underground headquarters
because he knew he'd be able to escape
from that easier because in the prison
room in his glass jail there's a grate
in the floor that leads underground tell
me a jail on earth that has a gray in
the floor i think about stuff like this
too in movies
i think about this stuff too that you
can get out through
name one jail
we're talking about mi6's jail let alone
a normal jail i can go to a normal jail
at the [ __ ] romanian police station
and they will not have a grate in the
floor that allows me to escape but mi6
has that great and no one's walked past
passed it in the jail room and thought
it's fine
what kind of [ __ ] is this then he
goes down in the grape and bond chases
him but because he's so smart he thought
ahead that bond was going to chase him
because when you're running and he's on
the ladder bonds behind him he's like
haha i have a surprise for you and
presses a button and blows up the roof
so the train can come and kill bond i'm
not understanding a lot of these
references because i have not seen any
of the movies any i've seen clips of
james bond
you know
but yeah none of the movies it's also
coming and he knows i'm not a movie
person it's just not my thing i'm a
youtube person that's why i'm on youtube
i watch youtube
trainers could be delayed because he's
psychic and uh why not put the ball more
bond would be just blow bond
i do hope that wasn't for me
why do you need to train because the
train misses why do you need to blow up
the thing to train why don't you just
have a bomb there for bondage okay oh
bombs here bang [ __ ] you
why why there's so many [ __ ] huge
holes
if if james bond has to go up and hide
in skyfall and they have to place these
stupid [ __ ] codes into the
program so the dude can find him and
know he's going there but he doesn't
want mi6 in all this [ __ ] he can't
do that while carrying a gun because if
he bond gets there he has a [ __ ] gun
can't you do all that while just
carrying a gun do the same thing but
just take a gun with you you can't do
that of course you [ __ ] can when bond
is on the frozen lake and shoots the
lake and falls in the water and the bad
guy's standing there and he just walks
off involves the bad guy but okay well
he's either gonna freeze to death or
he's gonna suffocate them too yeah that
happens all the time in movies where
people come back to life i'm like nobody
checked nobody found the body i that
happens a lot like in the
the black panther movie when he like
fell i'm like can you go to the bottom
and check
anyways building she's an old lady she
can't do [ __ ] so i'm gonna wait two
minutes for bomb's head to pop up and
blow his brains out i'll just you just
wait there with a gun
after a quick google search it turns out
tate is taller than all the past jb
actors hey i stand corrected
i stand correct i'm sorry he looks
short he looks short
holy hole in the ice hmm
it's been two minutes okay it's been
five minutes
okay six minutes he's toast all right
bond's dead now let me carry on city
falls in the ice he goes ha ha he's
falling in the ice
he must be gone forever no one's ever
got wet before and and and survived so
he must be gone forever let me just
march over here to end and then bond
reappears let's just pull up i reacted
to the wrong one
okay well
well
should i keep going with this one you
guys think or go to the other one that i
was supposed to react to i'll let you
guys i'll do a little more and you guys
can decide in the comments
[ __ ] so the movies sucked anyway they
already ruined the [ __ ] movies and
now they want to come along and make
bond a black female why
leave bond as he was
pisses me off but now you got me mad
about all the other movies [ __ ] money
penny money petty became a black female
and look what happened to her money
painting was a white female the whole
way through bond the same day they made
her a black female she shot bond with a
[ __ ] snipe rifle on accident oops
oops bang oops all the female oops just
like when they try and park and they
can't [ __ ] park she hits ball and he
falls off a train he basically dies and
when he sees her again she's like he's
like you nearly killed me and she's like
you can take it like some [ __ ] i
can't remember some attitude you respond
you're a tough guy
wow i have not seen this movie
i've been like [ __ ] you shot me with a
[ __ ] sniper rifle now you want to
give me attitude on top of that
okay that was kind of funny
this white bomb became a [ __ ] the old
bomber like why the [ __ ] did you shoot
me
oh you can take it shut the [ __ ] up talk
about take it or shoot me [ __ ] shoot
the bad guy what the [ __ ] wrong with
you so we already have bond being a
[ __ ] when money penny became a black
chick and she's [ __ ] giving him
hassle
after shooting him
on top of that bond was [ __ ] money
penny and there was an up there's one of
the clips where bond is calling money
penny and and she's on the phone and
he's like who's that guy there and she's
like well this is real life james
give me something else to react to i'm
getting bored of this one
[Music]
um okay james bond no time to die
die
hidden
[Music]
oh wait actually i'm gonna do um yours
right after this
um i forgot zach zach i'm gonna do yours
i'm only gonna do this because he
he requested
[Music]
in the rolls royce starry eyes got the
starry
roof
look at my other cars i'm james bond
and it was fun for a very long time but
i'm starting to get genuinely concerned
have you heard of the story of the sword
of damocles have you heard of that
never it's an old story i think it's
ancient greek
it's very very old and it's a story
about a king who did a lot of crazy
things a lot of brutal
horrible things to come to power and
once he came to power he could no longer
rule fairly or justly because he would
look weak in the eyes of his enemies so
he continued to do unfair and unjust
things
and the king damocles was sitting on his
throne
and all around his throne he had gold
are we going to get to the point
i got i got things to do andrew he had
beautiful women he had fruit he had
everything a man could desire and his
servant of many
many decades 30 40 years said i can't
imagine how it would feel to sit in that
throne i've seen you in that throne for
all of this time and all i can imagine
is the feeling of just sitting on that
throne and people adorn you i can't
possibly imagine
[Music]
there's
okay
[Music]
so he's saying oh so he's jade
said
the things i have done to get here the
things i've done to take my place on
this throne i mean it doesn't feel the
way you would imagine it but tomorrow
i'm gonna let you sit in the chair
so the slave couldn't sleep
the servant was awake all night
imagining the day he's finally gonna sit
in the throne and be able to grab fruit
what happened tell me andrew i have
kitties at random in this golden chair
you couldn't possibly imagine how
amazing it's gonna feel
but damocles wanted to replicate the
feeling
of
power because what happens when you're
powerful
is that people want what you have
that's very true
that's very true um and
you guys know i grew up in like a pretty
well-off family
it does cause a lot of like jealousy
from people and people are kind of like
waiting to see you fail in a way sort of
there's two ends of it no one cares that
much about you right okay
nobody
there's no one on the planet that cares
that much about you
however
it's almost like when things do go wrong
people are just kind of excited because
they've seen you you know prosper for so
long i guess but
yeah so damocles hung
a sword by a single horse's hair above
the throne
when the servant sat down for the first
few seconds he was a stag he was happy
until he looked up and he saw the suit
they start to panic and feel it easy
because he realized
that although you have all of the
worldly goods around you
still
there is
the things you have done to get there do
you understand it haunts you from the
past and it's hanging over your head and
at any moment you can die
and the slave didn't want to be in the
chair anymore
and he gave damn agrees to thrown back
that's the sort of damage makes now
i've been living that life for a while
but the difference between me and
everyone else is
when i look up at the sword
i appreciate its beauty
i see the glimmer of the sword in the
sunlight i think it's not beautiful
maybe one day it will fall
probably look pretty beautiful as it
falls just before i die what the are you
nuts sir
what the that's why i am where i am
that's why i've done the things nobody
else can do that's why i live the life
nobody else can live
well everyone says to me because i enjoy
i want your life you couldn't do what
i've done
i've told you all what i've done and you
still won't do it you can't do what i've
done because you couldn't handle
being me
the sword would frighten you
i've learned to fall in love with the
sword it's fine that's over my head
people have tried to kill me before
there are people in the world who are
actively planning to kill me right now
that's fine
all i can do is prepare to make sure
that i don't make it easy for them
so when i sit here with all my [ __ ]
around me and my beautiful cars in my
castle
and everyone's jealous of me i want you
to understand you are inferior to me
because of that you could not possibly
be where i am
i know you're thinking i actually do
think that's a good analogy because i
always say that most people
wouldn't want to be as successful as my
dad
now don't get me wrong my dad's a little
different than this man you know he he
lives in a castle
like a mansion right
with a wife and you know a million kids
but
teach his own right i mean how does this
all tie back to james bond but this ties
back to james bond heavily because
i actually
am james bond
when most people watch the bond movie
what they do is they immerse themselves
in fantasy
and they watch it and then they go back
to their four out of ten wife
and they read a book before checking in
to work tomorrow at 9 a.m because if
they're late their boss will tell them
off
they don't ever get to be the maverick
they don't ever get to break the rules
they don't ever get to be the guy who's
so [ __ ] good that despite the fact he
does nothing the way he's supposed to do
it they simply need him
i am that guy
what does he even do doesn't he sell
hookers or something
not hookers like cam campsites
you guys can correct me if i'm wrong
i'm gonna i'm gonna google this
did i i hope i didn't google anything
weird
um
okay google
what does
andrew
tay
do
for a living
i swore he he does campsites i know that
he he does the fighting i knew that
but i swore now he's
rich because of
personal life um
okay blah blah blah
what does he do
um
i don't see it on here
sir what do you do
no one in the comments is telling me but
maybe it'll come up in a second i'll
keep playing the video
mostly has been out here um okay wait
his brother tristan does the sights
andrew really owns casinos and krypto
okay
are blundering through life
with no skill set
amateurs
yeah i can fight yes i can yes i can
i've shown it all but it's not even
about that it's about the mentality that
bond has
most men look at a girl and they want to
[ __ ] her because she's beautiful
i will state with conviction besides
james bond and andrew [ __ ] oh my gosh
thanks for joining my memberships
you're my second i know this is sad but
you're my second member
my other one is my mom so it doesn't
really count
but
what a time
i'm gonna start doing
i'm it i'm gonna do like members-only
polls right now only my mom takes them
but you you sir will be pulled
and i'll i'll talk a little bit more
about that later but
i'm excited what a time okay we're the
last two people on the planet who will
look at a beautiful woman and think
i have to [ __ ] her so that she tells me
what i want to know
i have to [ __ ] her so she obeys me i
don't give a [ __ ] about having sex with
beautiful women i [ __ ] them so they
listen to me so i can get what i
actually want which is not them
it's a means to an end i don't get it i
don't get this at all
i i don't understand
every single bond girl was exploited
that's exactly what i do
so does that mean he slept with michaela
peterson to get to her dad
when i watch a bond film and i see him
basically pimp a [ __ ] to me that speaks
to my heart i've been there
i've done that and i need to know how i
need to exclusively know how this worked
in your life in real life who's followed
me long enough knows that i first made
my million dollars with a webcam
business i have met beautiful women
okay that's what i thought the webcam
because
is it bad that i respect money less if
you got it through sex work
even if you're the man managing the sex
work i'm sorry
i'm really sorry maybe maybe this is
wrong of me i don't know
i just i respect it less sorry
the good personality and thought she
will make me money i have to [ __ ] this
[ __ ]
i don't want to have sex or i just need
the money
ball needs the [ __ ] nuclear codes do
you understand i am james bond
people have tried to kill me i felt a
blade my skin has been penetrated by
murderous steel men out here haven't
they watched a james bond movie eat
their popcorn go back to starbucks go
back to their middle management they've
never been selling drugs to pay the rent
and someone's tried to i am not lemonade
bae i will not be typing that 909 i
don't want to see that
is it show the 919 guys oh no
[ __ ] kill them
bond sleeps lightly
watch the movie
you see that doesn't happen to me
[ __ ] three times a week i wake up and
grab the [ __ ] knife next to my
[ __ ] table
that's my exact life
i am actually [ __ ] james bond head to
toe
all the driving scenes you can see me do
all over youtube all the shooting all
the professional fighting outside of the
realms of fantasy the closest thing a
human being can be within the
constraints of the real world is me i'm
the closest possible thing to james bond
is he was he a really good fighter i
don't actually know i don't know
anything about fighting
the reason i am upset
is because these last few bond movies
have been telling me something oh the
okay then i'll look it up the sleeping
one and what they've been telling me
is that
for men like me
time is running out
in the 1950s 1960s 1970s bond could
humanize as i do
drive beautiful cars as i
drink as i do people say i'll take
confidential tate you never get hungover
all you do is drink
i don't want myself
to understand james bond is never
hungover you can't be hungover when
people are trying to
okay
okay
cap cat
you must survive
and for the longest time james bond
was the only other person on the planet
i could look at and go you know what
andrew you're not alone
there's someone else out there who's
living the life you live with all of the
things every man wants but couldn't
handle having
but these last few movies i think of
noticing starting to change if you
notice these last few movies bond is old
bonds ways are no longer needed
we need a new generation four-time world
champ oh go good for you good for you i
need the computer geeks we need the
people who listen to the system follow
the rules
and this
[Music]
fovid virus came along this is here now
follow the rules obey obey obey
mavericks are punished you're no longer
allowed to be a maverick no longer
allowed to think for yourself
when this fovid came
i realized i am absolutely alone on this
planet
i'm big on twitter right i'm in the
manosphere a bunch of other manosphere
guys big people with big followings
who are tough anti-establishment alpha
males everybody
collapsed
everybody cowered it out everyone all of
them
do my research i don't do research
but you're welcome to put any research i
should do in the chat to be honest it
was just me
by my [ __ ] self
who resisted the system who went to
sweden
and [ __ ] a bunch of women because what
would james bond do
he'd drink a martini
vodka martini chicken was stirred do i
look like i gave her them
he'd go to sweden and he'd think you
know what i need to see this city and
make important connections how was the
easiest way to do that let me get a
couple hot [ __ ] because they know all
the good places in the sea and i have
status when i walk in the place with
some hot [ __ ] i'm [ __ ] girls just
to conquer the city i don't need sex
oh okay oh so he hooks up with the hot
girls to get to cool places
that's what the interesting did we
literally conquered sweden instead of
two weeks
i am james who did he meet in sweden i
have so many questions
and these last few movies have told me
that my time is running out
and i just watched the last phone movie
and they made it very very clear that
people like bond are going to be
replaced
and that people like bond are no longer
needed and that people like bond are
going to be eradicated
so i have a choice
i either stop being james bond
or sooner or later
there is a near 100 percent chance
that i andrew tay end up in a jail cell
were dead
okay well i hope that does not happen
sir um okay
the next video is recommended let's see
it was by zack moore
and it is
well no fap
spike your test testosterone what is
nofap i don't know what that means
increase happiness increase confidence
increase motivation willpower lowered
stress you know all this stuff can be
helpful for some people and can actually
happen however it can also what i
noticed after a while it could
potentially
okay
what's up guys derek from placements.com
today we're going to be revisiting the
nofap discussion if you've seen uh
my video on nofap you kind of know my
stance on it from a guy's perspective
who is enhanced so if you don't know i'm
on trt and uh i did the nofap experiment
if you want to see my anecdotal report
you can go look at i'll put a card up in
the corner snow fab did anyone put in
the comments
um
i don't see it okay well we're
doing nofap on steroids and it's a bit
of a unique spin on the nofap challenge
because most guys doing it are natural
and um you know just thought i would see
how um it would affect my you know brain
chemistry i guess or how i respond to uh
you know everyday stressors and [ __ ] and
uh how skyrocketed my libido would go
all that kind of stuff you can see my
results in there but um as far as
naturals go obviously
you do need to explain it i don't know
what no fap is i don't you know
maintaining a steady state concentration
of tests with exogenous hormones is a
bit different than a guy who is
abstaining from busting a nut
which is like directly intertwined into
his endogenous testosterone production
like obviously you know your hpta or
hbga whatever you want to call it
is um
you know regulated essentially by
gonadotropins going down your testicles
and producing testosterone in your
goddamn testicles so this if you are
busting nuts is that going to lower your
test if you don't fap is that going to
cause a buildup of tests and a giant
spike where you end up getting uh you
know way more muscle growth or something
that's kind of what we're going to be
getting into and what the truth is and i
was looking into some of the clinical
literature on the subject and i found an
interesting article
um that kind of
summarized it and i think i get it
i thought it was a really uh well put
together article that kind of you know
did the work for me to be honest so is
that so do you guys like my new audio
setup i got a new mic i felt like my old
one i just didn't like let me know
digging into it they've consolidated the
very minimal data available and have a
conclusive opinion on what exactly
happens and i'll kind of give you my
stance you know tying it all together at
the end so here nofap is a growing
online movement devoted to giving up
masturbation even sex for extended
periods typically around 90 days
starting off as a spin-off from a 2011
threat on reddit the organization
nofap.com describes itself as a
community-centered sexual health
platform designed to help people
overcome porn addiction and compuls
compulsive sexual behavior the claim
benefits however have now extended the
reach of no fat beyond the realms of
porn addiction recovery into mainstream
health and lifestyle initiatives
advocates of nofap are heralding an
array of sexual physical and mental
improvements including increased
testosterone levels but is there any
evidence to back this up there's also
semen retention that people are doing
and um like this is basically a
chart here of the sexual physical mental
purported benefits what you can
basically expect like this i can
definitely attest to the fact that all
of this [ __ ] is pretty much accurate
with exception of
perhaps improved sexual self-regulation
like i guess
because you're not doing it you're not
literally busting nuts on a daily basis
you're self-regulating if that's what
that means but the rest of it is
definitely true
physical
energy levels this can paradoxically go
up and then down which we're gonna go
into later
a lot of this stuff is a little bit over
hyped but some of the stuff like
improved or cured erectile dysfunction
like so many guys who think they have ed
on steroids like some of them actually
do and it's you know hormonal imbalances
mismanagement of estrogen etc but a lot
of these guys too they're just so
[ __ ] horny and are like porn addicted
and have desensitized themselves selves
to pretty much everything sexual related
that they can only get like a half chub
watching like the most [ __ ] up porn
ever
oh gosh does that does that happen i
don't know anything about porn i've only
seen porn once
and it was in college because i said to
this guy i wasn't even like dating him
or anything we were just friends we were
in the dorm and i was like
i've never seen porn before
and then he looks at me and he says
i need to show you and i was like please
don't you don't need to do that but he
was determined so
yeah apparently he had like a group porn
account with his friends where they paid
for premium
like all together
i was like that is
weird um but okay
yeah so
i don't
that's my one experience anyways
and they do it like multiple times a day
and then they wonder why they have ed
even though they're on a bunch of
steroids they think it's the steroids in
reality their libido skyrocketing from
the steroids and then they're letting
their brains run wild and do [ __ ] up
like binges of porn to the point where
they're dick's essentially like numb
and they have to watch like super weird
[ __ ] up [ __ ] just to feel something
and then they blame it on the gear and
it's like like i guess hypothetically it
comes indirectly from the gear perhaps
from your increased libido but it's like
a lot of this is just willpower too like
a lot of guys who think they have
problems with you know like in bed not
you know being able to stay hard with
the chick first thing i tell them is
don't fap for a week and don't watch
porn for a week and then see how your
performance is seven days
oh my gosh i feel so uncomfortable
this is not what i was expecting you
guys to send me let me tell you from now
and then tell me if there's no no
difference whatsoever and it's highly
unlikely that that won't be the that you
will encounter the same performance
issues like it's highly likely you will
notice improvements that's not always
the case i'm just saying it's a good
like first like easy free thing that's
non-hormonal not anything you just
[ __ ] don't touch your dick and don't
watch porn and then see what happens
after a week um increased happiness
increased confidence increase motivation
willpower lowered stress you know all
this stuff can that's good right so i
guess this is a good thing can be
helpful for some people and can actually
happen however it can also what i
noticed after a while it could
potentially be almost counterproductive
where your mind is so consumed by sexual
thoughts that you're almost better off
getting off
in order to get it out of your head so
you can get back to work like that's the
annoying thing once you have this [ __ ]
built up and it doesn't even it's not
even just about willpower after a while
so you have so much pent-up [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's uh
you know it's just like consuming your
mind you're like trying to work and
you're like you know have a perpetual
[ __ ] hard-on it's not exactly easy to
focus on your work so anyways getting
into the actual
that's a problem that you do not think
about as a girl
you did not think about this benefits
and whatnot in a clinical aspect in
terms of does it spike your testosterone
um like obviously testosterone does have
profound effects on mood and whatnot as
far as the actual evidence though two
studies mainly pop up as the evidence
reinforcing the kind of movement
in the first one 10 men had their
testosterone levels measured twice
baseline before masturbation orgasms
several tests are more reliable than
just one i can't even imagine being the
participants in this study oh no and
then in 10 minute intervals after this
was followed by a three-week period in
which they instructed to refrain from
any type of sexual activity after that
period the process was repeated
testosterone was reported as being
higher in the baseline measurements
after abstinence despite the conclusions
of the research the sample size of the
study was tiny i agree and the increase
in testosterone may have actually been
due to the anticipation of sexual
arousal in the second experiment after
abstinence what's more testosterone
levels at the first baseline measurement
were actually the same before and after
abstinence you know it's like
testosterone levels are so drastically
affected by so many things in your
lifestyle
sleep hygiene etc that it's like
very hard to attribute anything to a 10
person study so i would not take a whole
lot from that to be honest um like you
could literally have like one night of
shitty sleep and boom your test levels
for the day are
you know not as good as they could be
like they could be substantially
hindered just by you know a couple days
of having like you eat way too close to
bedtime and you know you you have a
shitty sleeper whatever it is and like
whatever it is that interferes with with
your sleep it's way too hot in your room
whatever it is and all of a sudden you
know your test levels are you know
periodically down [ __ ] 10 20 or
something like this is not
it's very very
manipulated by a lot of different
factors that may otherwise interfere
with something with a sample size so
minimal so i would definitely not take a
lot from it
second study reported a 45 increase in
test levels after seven days of
abstinence but this was a temporary peak
which then returned to the same levels
as before even with continued abstinence
and stayed that way such transient
alterations and test levels are unlikely
oh my god ellie
oh god
ellie
my dog just oh my god
oh my god
um okay so this is five by three
huh i guess it makes sense well then
what do they do if they if they have
like a
heart like how do they oh god i feel
uncomfortable
to have any lasting effects on men's
health that may primarily serve as a
regulator of creation of new sperm a few
studies on the other end have shown
either no effect of abstinence on tests
or that test was actually higher after
masturbation or sex measuring tests
before and directly after masturbation
in 34 healthy young men found that test
levels increased after self-stimulation
but any longer-term effects were not
checked at best the evidence linking
masturbation with changes in test levels
is limited
and with mixed conclusions
um so
you know again there's psychological
reasons too that could otherwise like
basically here's my stance after you
know some of the data like it's
interesting the you know week-long
abstinence leading to a spike in test in
the real world what do you see it really
play out that first week you notice like
it's very very difficult to adhere to is
it just because it's not a part of a
routine for you or like it is part of
your routine you're trying to remove it
from your someone said in the comments
um
that
basically
there are benefits to nofap
i'm personally like a once a week every
two weeks i don't
the
the topic of masturbation just makes me
very uncomfortable i don't even know if
i could say it on youtube but i just did
so
um
but
i don't know
sorry this is the worst thing you guys
could have sent me to react to because i
don't know anything about this routine
but it's like a habit so it's very hard
to quit is it that your body actually
ramps up when it thinks it is you know
deprived of sex and is trying to you
know procreate and it's like go [ __ ]
people like that's basically what it's
trying to get you to do and getting you
more aggressive and whatnot you know the
i heard someone say that
it makes it so
you can't um
go
that if you don't
have
if you have porn like it makes you less
motivated to go like find a real girl
actual
spike in test levels how much is it
going to be and is it going to be
sustained you know personally i would
not be surprised if there is maybe a
transient bump but what we do seem to
find at least anecdotally in a lot of
these reports are you get a big spike in
aggression and you know volatility even
in your first week and then after you
sort of get used to the nofap after a
while things sort of dip down you know
this is at least anecdotally maybe not
for everyone but from what i've seen in
my research research you know anecdotal
findings is that after the first you
know little hill you have to climb you
know you've reached like a peak of
aggression and then after that you
either you know you almost go back down
it's kind of interesting how it works
there's a lot of individuals who will
report they get a big [ __ ] spike
after a week and then after a while it
becomes far easier to adhere to not
fapping and they eventually get to a
point where they almost don't even want
to and it makes you wonder is it like a
use it or lose it thing you know like
there's a lot of things in the body that
seem to be regulated by in fact like you
know stimulating it to a point where it
makes you wonder like is fapping
intermittently perhaps
ideal versus like i think we can all
agree that doing it on a daily basis
multiple times a day or something is
[ __ ] you know terrible it's kind of
weird how normal
how normal like that like porn is
um a lot of girls
will say because i've had these
conversations behind the scenes that
they really
don't um
have i put it like
the idea of their partner doing that
stuff but at the same time they don't
think it's cheating and it's kind of too
much to ask for someone what do you guys
think what do you think girls have the
right to be mad about you watching porn
do you think a girl has the right to ask
you not to watch porn
i'm kind of on the boat of i just don't
want to know
obviously i'd prefer no not but
i just don't want to know terrible the
amount of prolactin spike the amount of
you becoming a lazy bastard that can
occur from that in just a [ __ ]
psychological aspect definitely a real
thing like there's not a it's not a
coincidence that you feel so relaxed and
so lethargic after like your body has
literally accomplished its goal and is
now in a mindset like literally
neurochemically to just like relax and
like do [ __ ] nothing so like doing
the opposite of that
getting your body into a place where
it's urging itself to go do things and
be motivated to go after you know
procreating i guess is the main you know
physiologic goal of it um i definitely
think there's a mechanism there whereby
if you do abstain from fapping and
especially porn um you will get
i don't know if it's going to be a surge
in test that is representative in every
single individual but there's definitely
a spike in aggression and
definitely about a girlfriend who was
cool with watching porn with him
and enjoyed it there are girls like that
i have a lot of i know a lot of girls
that watch porn because
i've i say that i've never watched porn
minus you know i don't really count that
one time like i said you can kind of
count it but whatever um
like i have a lot of friends i've talked
to about this and i am definitely in the
minority and most girls i talk to have
watched porn at some point a real spike
in motivation and drive overall which i
definitely think can have actual
benefits in a entrepreneurial aspect
self-improvement aspect dating like how
many guys will you know
relegate themselves to pornhub and just
like you know deal with the fact that
it's so easily accessible to bust a nut
rather than go put in the work and the
actual [ __ ] you know getting a chick
like it's a lot easier to sit on your
computer and rub one out than it is to
actually you know yeah that's what
someone said in the chat oh put in the
work and find a high quality woman that
you want to spend time with you know
this is the kind of [ __ ] that a lot of
guys will subject themselves to simply
out of laziness and lack of drive and
this gets reinforced further by the
constant busting of nuts and
desensitizing their brains with porn to
a point where they literally have no
actual willpower to go [ __ ] find
mates essentially
so
yeah i think nofap has benefits in
certain individuals i don't think it's
necessarily useful for everyone i don't
necessarily buy that it's going to spike
your testosterone levels and
subsequently maintain those heightened
levels for long periods of time however
i do think there are psychological
benefits that can be
redirected okay is there one negative
i'm thinking is
could
there be a negative
making guys desperate when they approach
because
some guys they act like you they owe you
sex oh my gosh the other i'm gonna make
a vlog and i talk about this in the vlog
that's coming out the other night me my
friend we went out i don't drink right
so
i'm very rational when i go out or
whatever just because
i don't know like i'm sober and we're
talking to this guy
and he literally
i'm not gonna tell the story
very
guys can get desperate like very
desperate and they act like like they
you owe them and i wonder if porn helps
with that makes them less desperate now
i'm just thinking a lot i can't imagine
okay the energy pent up redirected into
things that are more productive and help
you reach goals you know i don't
necessarily think it's for everyone but
i definitely do think there is
a psychological aspect that can be
manipulated in a way that is beneficial
to certain lackadaisical individuals
that are otherwise just floating through
life with not much meaning and can't
really apply themselves to things i do
think they should retain that energy and
redirect it into useful applications so
i don't know let me know what you guys
think in the comments down below do you
have any experience with nofap do you
have any before and after blood work to
reinforce if it does yeah desperate
ellie
yeah pearl
um desperation is a terrible thing to
deal with
yeah because we can smell it on you guys
it is it is not cute it it is not cute
we do
i do not like guys that get
too forward and like touchy with me too
soon and people will say
oh it's
like because you view them as beta i'm
like
[Music]
it's pretty consistent let me tell you
does indeed spike test levels or not if
they're subsequently maintained
thereafter like what i would want to see
is a guy who has
multiple different base lines of blood
work based on you know like averages on
multiple weeks subsequently after the
first one
um on the same diet model on the same
training regimen on the same sleep
protocol and the slam everything
multiple baselines and get an average of
those and then introduce the nofap and
then get multiple averages after that
and then sort of compare the averages
you know and see what's going on there
and get a more indicative um assessment
of what's going on rather than you know
having uh you know like and this would
be your own individual thing not based
on a 10 person sample size because how
are you going to figure out what's
applicable for you
if you are referencing you know a study
that has 10 people in it obviously this
would be something you'd have to
replicate it says agreed watch it just
for release so you're not weird during
the day i'm not telling you guys to do
that i'm asking the question do not
confuse me asking a question
i'm not a guy
i don't don't confuse them on your own
and if they were gonna do a study with
it you know that would be sort of a
model i'd like to see you know with more
more people obviously but i don't
necessarily think that's ever going to
happen i don't necessarily think it's a
good use of resources
uh like to basically that's good advice
might have i start looking at having
conversations with women as the goal
rather than a means to an end
that way you don't catch yourself trying
to force attraction yeah i agree with
that yes reinforce something that you
could otherwise test for yourself i
forgot someone told me that you should
wait
um that you should it was like
wait three weeks or whatever to make her
comfortable something like that
and i think the more patient you can be
as a guy
i don't know the more you'll probably
get out of it self for free if something
has a benefit for you obviously the
blood work not being free but the actual
testing of the theory
being free and if anything being
profitable because you save money by
having more free time to do things so um
i definitely think it's worth a try for
everyone who is curious but i don't
necessarily think it is definitively a
okay i'm not gonna keep going with that
um i think someone says woman has sex
wait shoot woman
has sex with
919 something like that
oh god
it's two minutes okay
so i'm gonna watch this woman holds a
record by having sex with a 919 man also
guys if you're watching this and you
don't subscribe
help a girl out okay if you've watched
three or more of my videos and you're
watching this live and you don't
subscribe we have beef
real beef okay
let's watch
[Music]
guys you're welcome to our youtube
channel exhibit junior if you are new
here please subscribe if you subscribe
hit the notification bell and stay
connected for more entertaining news
updates guys it seems like nowadays
there is a record book for just about
everything under the sun let's meet this
woman she is called lisa's park this
aspect set a whole world record for
sleeping with 919 men in just 24 hours
919 men oh no
no
this is amazing and impossible what led
lisa supposed to sleep with 919 men she
set this record on october 16 2004 in
warsaw that is poland during the adult
convention eruption 2004 the actress
took the challenge as part of the third
anwar
world gangback championship where she
was competing against two other women
this laser sparks was competing
with two other women who was also
fighting for this championship oh my god
you have to be numb at that point that
is not cute that is not why do we live
in a society where like this is
is a thing for what that's who you want
your legacy to be
sleeping with a lot of guys that's so
gross that's you want to be remembered
by
but eliza sparks won the competition by
having sex with
990 men over a period of 12 hours in
order to set the record the men were
only allowed 45 seconds with the actress
one of the women she was competing
against was the former world record
holder who had sex with 759 men in a day
on the day
that's gross
sent your sister a dm do not
go talk to my sister
i mean i mean
i don't care if you guys you know hit on
her or whatever but i do not
appreciate
um
you guys like sent you guys have sent
messages to my friends and family that
were not very nice and i don't need that
first one the competition after having
sex with 21 more men than the person who
came second guys
can you imagine losing you did all that
for what for what if you have not yet
subscribe to our youtube channel
oh god that's so gross
um
um
okay let's see what other videos are on
here
one of their videos um they said
previous react
andrew tate on fresh and fit
okay this is two hours and 19 minutes i
will not be doing that
is there a clip
um
no there's no limit on how many you can
send me it doesn't mean i'll pick it but
there is no limit how many you can
request or send me
i could do this hi 19 year olds
oh
firestone
andrew tape fresh and fit firestone is
that what you're talking about
or is that a different
oh i'm so confused
um
um
i will find you one day i will find you
that is creepy sir
you're gonna get blocked from this chat
um
oh no i'm not doing i'm not doing songs
today i'm gonna do song reactions a
different day
um
fresh and fit andrew tate clip
we'll do a clip
um
hot 19 year olds what do you guys think
of that
i'll do this
okay
i have an instagram people dm me stuff
it's just at pearly things i think i
need to update my link because i
switched my username
but it's just that pearly thing
[Music]
you went viral
for saying depression isn't real uh-oh
oh yeah i went and i want big time viral
yeah
yeah everybody all of hollywood was
gutting for me right they they were very
upset i told the truth can we talk about
that and your views on depression not
being real and you give the the
toxically masculine unfiltered raw side
of it well depression is another weapon
they use to imagine to destroy our
masculine energy right that's enough oh
you're trying to get the other two guy
to stop oh okay i thought you're talking
to me we're cool we're cool man i won't
block you it takes me a lot for me to
block somebody weapon to use sorry let
me let me start this over also guys if
you're watching don't forget to
subscribe to the channel ring the
notification bell okay turn on my
notifications
um you have to like go to the
nevermind i don't even know how to
describe it but there's like a belt
thing and you click and you do turn on
all notifications and then you'll be
notified when i post a video i usually
post
more than five videos a week
okay
[Music]
you went viral
for saying depression isn't real uh-oh
oh yeah i went and i want big time viral
yeah everyone jk rowling yeah everybody
all of hollywood was gutting for me
right they were very upset i told the
truth can we talk about that and your
views on depression not being real and
you get give the
um i think depression's real
um but i do think that people don't
typically
do everything they can to fix it
before taking drugs
they they rush to drugs before they try
changing their diet exercise
all that stuff
the toxically masculine unfiltered raw
side of it well depression is another
weapon they use to imagine to destroy
our masculine energy right that's
another weapon they use because the
majority of depressed people are men men
suffer from depression more than females
because because a man's life is worse
than the females like a man's life is
much harder right so another way they
destroy us is they they convince us to
be absolutely selfish depression is
nothing but extreme selfishness that's
what i'm gonna call it and we're gonna
i'm gonna tell you why it's not real in
a second but if you're depressed you're
living inside of your mind you're
obsessed with how you feel you don't
care about anything outside of yourself
and you're an exceptionally selfish
person that's all they're trying to do
is convince you and teach you to be
extremely selfish let me tell you
something
i'm going to say this right here right
now because there's a whole bunch of
famous people lincoln park or whatever
they kill themselves if you have
children
and you kill yourself
you're not a man i don't care what
you're feeling i don't i do
i do think that suicide is selfish
i think it's really sad and i'm really
empathetic to people that have those
thoughts but i do think suicide's
selfish because you're thinking about
the way you feel above everyone else and
that's the definition of selfish care
how sad you are you have children to
take care of you're going to embarrass
your children you're going to leave your
children without a father and you're
going to say that
because you're sad if you have children
and you kill yourself you are never a
man to begin with
absolute garbage garbage and and the
only reason this crap happens is because
of the acceptance of depression people
say that depression is stigmatized it's
the complete opposite it's accepted now
to the point where it's almost promoted
it's insane let me tell you something
depression is not real
feeling depressed
is real
so you can feel you can feel depressed
but you feel depressed and that is a
natural biological evolutionary trigger
for you to change something in your life
that's that's your own mind telling you
that's true
that's true i think depression is a
trigger to change
things in your life that's true you're
unhappy about x if i went to jail today
i'd be depressed because i'm in jail i
haven't caught depression i don't
here's the thing i think that people
say things with no leeway
and and
the most crazy way possible to get
clicks and to get views
um
i do think
there's enough evidence of like
biological differences in the brain of
people with depression and enough
evidence
i don't want to say i've like spent a
ton of time researching this but i've
seen enough credible people
talk about it that it seems like it's a
real thing
but um do i think a lot of it's
situational sure i think what he's
saying is absolutely true if you go to
jail you probably will be depressed i
don't have a disease i'm just upset with
my situation yep i have people miss me
all the time i'm fat and i can't get a
girlfriend because i'm depressed i'm
like no
pancake lover
[Music]
you're depressed because you're fat and
you can't get a girlfriend do you
understand
this is the point right so for a lot of
people your life is depressing a lot of
you out there if you're sitting there
and you say you suffer from depression
you probably live a depressing life you
probably live a depressing life so if i
was you i'd be depressed but if you were
me you'd be happy you know what could
solve depression for most poor people a
million dollars on the bank
then why
don't lottery winners
end up happy why do they end up
broke again
pearly depression fundamentally
undermines your motivation to do things
i said that i believe depression is real
i would not go as far to say that it is
not real but there are cases where it is
your situation
so how is it a disease so when i say
this to people most of them agree and
they go okay but if that's true why do
famous people kill themselves and i say
well i know you think you outsmarted me
but i'm andrew tate
and i have the answer
the reason is twofold this absolute
acceptance of depression and acceptance
of weakness when you accept anything to
a degree you're promoting it weakness is
promoted now in men right so let's take
robin williams as an example robin
williams killed himself i was just going
to say robin williams right famous he
could be banging 19 year olds the rest
of his life multi-millionaire everyone
loves him how could he possibly kill
himself i'll tell you why
because i swore he was sick that's what
my dad told me he was sick and that's
why he killed himself he walked into the
therapist's office and said i feel
depressed the therapist said okay here's
some mind-altering drugs start taking
these and then i need to see you six
hours a day every day and we're going to
talk about sad things for the next 10
years because he was in therapy therapy
for 10 years
if i had to take behind altering drugs
and talk about sad [ __ ] for six hours a
day for 10 years i'd kill myself
but if he would have walked into the
therapist did he actually do that six
hours a day
this is a little bit of a stride
you're robin williams there are people
in the world with no food yeah there are
families in syria there are school buses
being bombed in yemen there are people
who lost their entire family in a car
crash today you're roman williams and
everyone you love is in perfect time
people always
like famous people kill themselves all
the time and are very depressed
you're a selfish idiot get out of my
office get some balls he'd still be
alive today
the cure made it worse and this whole
society of accepting depression as soon
as someone's depressed instantly go to
them oh poor you it's okay we know you
can't help it you can't help it why are
you telling people they can't help it
that's not what i would say i would say
that to do everything you can to not
take drugs before you do
why are you reinforcing that mindset in
people if you come to me and say you're
depressed i say i will fix you
and you know what's crazy when i said
this depression thing wasn't real do you
know how many people
stuck up for depression you don't
understand i'm depressed depression's
real that i was like if it's so horrible
why are you defending it you sound like
it's a pr team
i thought it was ruining your life but
you are desperate for me to believe in
it you want me to believe in it you're
sticking up for it you're defending
depression try to convince me it's real
because it's your cure-all excuse for
failure when you're depressed you can
fail in every human metric i fail at
everything but i'm depressed it's not my
fault no you're a failure that's all you
are because you're not trying very hard
if you live in a house i say this all
the time this is the reason i don't
believe in depression because i don't
believe in depression i cannot become
depressed bam no matter what the worst
thing that could possibly
okay
to me on earth i will feel sad but i
will recover and i will not become
depressed because i don't believe in
depression if you're in an old haunted
house haunted house right you have two
people in two haunted houses one
believes in ghosts and one doesn't
you hear some noise in the night the
wind blows right
the man who believes in ghosts is like
oh no a ghost now he's scared right he
wants an exorcist he's starting he can't
sleep he's scared about ghosts he's
paranoid the guy who doesn't believe in
ghosts goes wind whatever goes back to
sleep that's what i do
oh my gosh i don't know if ghosts are
real or not
but it's easier to not believe in them i
i do that because
mentally if i'm thinking about ghosts
i don't want to know i don't want to
know sleep
do you understand that it's the belief
that gives it power right if you don't
believe in ghosts the ghost can't hurt
you if you don't believe in depression
you can't become depressed and i refuse
to believe in something that's going to
weaken me
why would i believe in something that's
going to weaken my ability to deal with
problems in life why would i do that
i'm temporarily immortal
do you understand
do you understand
yeah i could see that a little bit
temporarily immortal and i'm not gonna
waste my living years believing in
things which take power from me
because i'm not an idiot so if you're
gonna sit there and go depression is
real actually you don't understand the
problems i'm going through you're a
[ __ ] you are a [ __ ] and the great
thing about morons is as you lose
there's no light without dark right
there's there's no there's no joy
without pain of course for me to be a
winner i need there needs to be losers
[Music]
but you're not going to convince me to
join your way of thinking the last thing
anyone who's watching this won't
understand the last thing you should
ever do is adopt the thinking of someone
who is sad
bam
why would you want to think like the sad
person
i'm sad and i'm just semi-suicidal you
should have the same views and beliefs
as me
what the sheep get the [ __ ] out of here
depression
it ain't real there i'm just blowing out
the water it's not real you can come at
me and say whatever you want it's not
real
[Music]
i'm not i'm not a science person but
i've just seen enough people that know
what the [ __ ] they're talking about
say that it's real and this guy
i don't think has any medical training
or medical background
so
i don't think it's really fair to say i
don't think it's fair it's not fair to
say i don't feel depression therefore
it's not real i don't believe in it
therefore it's not real i'm someone i
really haven't had a ton of mental
health issues like here and there maybe
a little bit but
naturally i'm just a pretty happy person
so
i don't think i'll ever i'll never feel
depression the way that someone that's
actually depressed feels it
android say in the house guys i i've
said it too man especially as a man
your
accomplishments right from your
competence creates confidence yeah most
of the time these guys that are
depressed it's because they haven't
accomplished anything they're sitting at
home crying you're depressed because
your life's depression you wake up
you're fat you're lonely you go to the
fridge there's no milk ah i can't have
cheerios that's it i'm depressed of
course yo that's because you're living a
depressing lifestyle if you woke up
sexy
like me you'd be okay but this is the
thing as a man you need to build your
value this has all been discussed a
million times before all the things i
have are things i've got myself oh my
god if you have nothing worth having
you're gonna look at the person
send a donation
so i can afford i wanna bring guys i
don't have the money for it right now
but i want to get a couple mics like
this and bring over like girls off my
volleyball team and just like people in
london
to have conversations about
relationships but
in all seriousness i am running out of
money
um i know everyone says oh you're rich
you have access to your parents bank
account um i don't
um i make money through views on this
tick tock and instagram
so
respectfully if you can afford it and
you like my content and that's something
you'd want to see that is what i'm
saving for right now
um
it doesn't have to be anything crazy but
like just a five dollar donation i would
really really appreciate it um
okay i'm gonna do maybe one maybe two
maybe two if you guys give me a donation
i'll do another
but i'm gonna do one last one
um okay let's see
see this guy sent me
zack you sent me
the troll leader is black okay
i really don't enjoy listening to andrew
tate that much um
the troll leader is black i don't know
it didn't come up someone sent me the
link to this
but i don't want to open my instagram
dms in front of everyone
oh it's unlisted sir
i can't i need a public one sorry i
can't pull up my instagram in front of
everyone
i'm not kevin samuels
um
what else do we got i really don't want
to watch andrew tate right now
um
see what else is in the chat
actually let me see something hold on
hold on
i can save to watch later and access it
on youtube
oh gosh uh okay i'm probably not gonna
watch that one but it's not
i i only watch videos that have a lot of
views already um
it's just more
it's like better for my time
no offense it's just you know
how it is
um
let's see what's on my
search page
andrew you will have to send a donation
for me to do that one
sir um
uber boyo
uh
no
let's see what we got
can you send another yeah
i don't know if you guys have seen
kelly's stamps i really enjoy her videos
oh you know what i could do
the michaela rolo interview i think i'm
too tired to do this one right now the
michaela rolo
but i do want to react to that this week
hot sauce no i'm not doing music tonight
i'm going to do a whole music stream
though i want to do them like once a
week and then i'm going to cut them up
um
um
it's actual psychology
uh have you guys this guy is so funny
actually i'm kind of getting tired
i'm getting really tired um
okay i'm actually gonna end the stream i
think
yeah um
i'll go longer
next time
but yeah i'm gonna stream tonight
send a donation if you can
because